- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey today's message
is be authentic.
Over to you Oprah Winfrey.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso going to keep me goin'
♫ Every morning
- I think that success is a process.
And I believe that my first
Easter speech in Kosciusko Baptist Church
at the age of three and a half
was was the beginning.
And that every other speech,
every other book I read,
every other time I spoke in public was
was a building block.
So that by the time I
first sat down to audition
in front of a television
camera and somebody says,
"Read this."
what allowed me to read it so comfortably
and be so at ease with myself at that time
was the fact that I've
been doing it a while.
If I've never read a book
like never spoken in public
before I would have
been traumatized by it.
So, the fact that
we went on the air with The
Oprah Winfrey Show in 1986
nationally.
And people say oh but you see
how you're so comfortable
in front of camera,
you can be yourself.
Well it's because I've been
being myself since I was 19.
And I would not have I
would not have been able
to be as comfortable with myself
had I not made mistakes on the air
and been allowed to make
mistakes on the air.
And understand that it
doesn't matter you know.
There's no such thing to me
as an embarrassing moment
no such thing.
If I tripped and fell,
if my bra strap showed,
if my slip fell off if,
I fell flat on my face
there's no such thing as
an embarrassing moment
because I know that there is not a moment
that I could possibly
experience on the air
that somebody else hasn't
already experienced.
So when it happens you say
oh, my slip fell off and it's no big deal.
I mean like I was on TV the
other day and somebody says,
"Oprah, you have a run."
Have you not seen a run
before in your life?
Well I get them too, let me tell you.
So I mean I can't be embarrassed.
I can't be embarrassed.
Now when I first started
out that was not true
because I was under the
I was pretending to be
somebody I was not.
I was pretending to be Barbara Walters.
So I'd go to a news conference
and I was more interested in
how I phrased the question
and how eloquent the question sounded.
As opposed to listening to the answer.
I so, which always happens
when you're interested
in impressing people instead of doing what
you're supposed to be doing.
And it took me awhile, it
took me messing up on the air
on during the live newscast.
I was doing a list of foreign countries
there was all these foreign names and
then Canada was thrown in
and I call Canada Cannada.
And I got so tickled that I called Cana,
I thought that wasn't
Cannada, that was Canada.
Excuse me that wasn't
Canada, that wasn't Cannada
that was Canada.
And then I started laughing.
well it was it was it became a, it became
the first real moment I ever had.
And the news director later
said to me, "Well if you
"do that then you should just keep going.
"You shouldn't correct
yourself and let people know."
I know, well who's ever heard our Cannada?
So that was for me the
beginning of realizing that
oh you can laugh at yourself
and you can make a mistake
and it's not the end of
the world you don't have to be perfect.
And biggest lesson for me for television
because then it didn't
matter, it didn't matter.
Oh sorry, bra strap's showing.
- Not being afraid to make
mistakes is one of the
hardest things to learn how to do.
And probably one of the most useful and
important things that you can learn
not just as an entrepreneur,
but as a human being.
You know when I first
started doing YouTube
I was terrified of making a mistake.
I was terrified of what
you guys would think.
I was terrified of putting
out an imperfect product.
I was trying to memorize
lines and in my first videos
they were really they were really fake
it was a fake version of me
because I was trying to
get the exact words right.
Everyone knows Walt Disney for
his movies, and theme parks,
and cast of characters.
But most people don't know
is when he first started out
he had no money, he had
to live in his office
because he couldn't afford
rent for an apartment.
And he survived on a diet of cold beans
because we couldn't afford food.
I would be sitting down
I'd be you know looking up
trying to memorize my lines.
And when I realized with
much more practice was that
it doesn't matter the
exact words that I use.
It's more than feeling,
it's more the genuineness.
And it's taking me a lot of
times it get through that.
I've made 5,000 videos now
and I've been working on it
and working on it and working on it.
And I wish there were a lot more actual
genuine moments too.
And I wish there were more mistakes.
I don't really make a ton of bloopers
when I'm making these video.
My team was always worried about
walking through shots.
And I'm actually excited
I think we got one
where Alex was picking up a table
and moving it out.
Like I'm cheering and I'm pumped up that
he's in the shot, that we made
a kind of blooper, a mistake.
Did we get Alex in there?
Yeah nice.
Nice I love it.
I love it.
Even last month when my
audio didn't work properly
you guys gave me a ton a ton
it's probably the most negative comments
in the history of our channel.
Every video we put up we
got comments about the echo
and am I in a cave and
people wanted to fly here
to buy me a mic.
And some of them were funny
and some of them were just
super hate and negative.
And I kept the videos up
because I make mistakes right
because I make mistakes,
my teammates makes mistakes
we're still human.
And I wanted to use that as look
here's the channel that
has 800,000 subscribers
and we're still making mistakes
and we're still trying
to figure things out.
And that's authentic for
me and so I think that
the biggest thing is one,
just realizing, having the
awareness to understand
that you are holding
yourself back because of fear
of judgment, fear of not being yourself,
fear of what people might think about you.
Most of the time we do things
that are so just subconscious
and we don't take action on it.
Recognizing that here's a moment right now
where you are afraid to do something
because of how somebody might judge you
and then doing something about it
and then taking action against it
and then slowly building up that muscle
so that the next time it happens
you're able to expand your
comfort zone a little bit more.
And just being able to
recognize that in your head
you have this rational,
you rationalize it,
you cope with all the
reasons why you shouldn't
be doing something but really
it's just that you're afraid.
If you can get to the deeper
cause of I'm just afraid
that's okay, I'm going
to push through this
and I'm going to expand my
comfort zone and get stronger
and stronger each time.
Having that awareness and
then doing something about it
will help you become more authentic.
And it doesn't just help you in business
people want to deal with people,
people want to understand your story,
people want to feel like
they connect to you.
People connect to me
more now than they did
when I first started and
I have the same message
that I did when I started.
It's just the way I deliver
it, it's much more authentic.
And so if you want to reach
people and have them take action
and grow your business,
authenticity is really important.
You hear that message over
and over again on the channel
but also just helps you as a human being
to know that you can be yourself,
be comfortable in your own skin,
not be constantly worried
when you're out at parties
or in social events of how
people might be seeing you
and judging you.
If you're if that's the world you live in
when you're constantly afraid
of how people are seeing you
then you're never actually
going to be yourself
and that is not a happy place to be.
And so that awareness to
understand when you're
holding yourself back and then to actually
do something about it,
take the action even though you're afraid,
do that consistently and
you'll see a significant growth
not just in your personal life
but also in your business.
So the question today is I'm
curious what is the thing
that you have the hardest
time being authentic about,
the thing you have the hardest
time being your true self
about leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
And if you leave a comment
within the first couple hours
of this video going live
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Penelope Stansfield
from greenfrog.fr.
Penelope thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word.
It really really means a lot to me.
And I hope you are enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Enpresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ Every morning
(keyboard typing)
- Adopt the mode of
authentic being.
And that is something like
refusing to participate in
the lie, in deception in the lie.
To orient your speech as much
as you can towards the truth.
And to take responsibility
for your own life
and perhaps also for the
lives of other people.
And there's something about
that that's meaningful
and responsible and noble
but also serves to
mitigate the very suffering
that produces say denialism or the
flee into the arms of or or the or
or the escape into the arms of
totalitarians to begin with.
You need something to shelter you against
your own vulnerability.
- You know you're watching
a movie and you hear a line
and it feels like oh they thought that was
going to be a line in the trailer.
Like you just know that
on the set someone's like
that's a trailer mode, like it doesn't
because it doesn't feel
real necessarily in life
but it just feels like
ah, it's a great sound
but it's a great thing.
That there's a visual equivalent of that.
And you got to be really
careful because sometimes
I'll think, ah, this is
like one of those moments
and then you end up
doing it and the truth is
it ends up feeling posed, it
just doesn't feel authentic.
I try for those sometimes
they never seem to work.
I think that the key for any of this stuff
and you know whether we've
accomplished it or not
is up to the audience.
But I think that the key
to any movie working.
Certainly a movie called
Star Trek which you know
could you know be seen as campy
is finding authenticity.
And and it's whether
it's in a little nuance,
a little moment, a character exchange,
a look, a glance, or a huge plot point
there's something for me that is
if I don't really
understand what's going on,
if I can't really get into under the skin
of these characters, none of the
spectacle is going to matter.
- And I give it my all I mean I
I practice every day and I try and stay
authentic and uncompromising.
We don't play any you
know crowd-pleasing stuff.
We don't you know get out there and play
When The Saints Go Marching In.
And you know will we play
blues, hymns, ragtime,
whorehouse music.
Stuff that was authentically New Orleans.
And we play it in the New
Orleans style as best we can.
And so I don't feel that I'm a sellout.
I'm doing the best I can.